Come from the data science stay for the meats.
Hello world it Saroj and data science is the hottest career to get into this
year.
Every industry is collecting customer data and using it to make smarter
decisions,
which leads to higher profits.
The demand to fill data science positions is through the roof globally and
forecast reveal that this demand will only increase in the coming years.
So to help you take part in this rapidly growing field,
I've created a three month curriculum to take you from absolute beginner to
proficient in the art of data science.
This open source curriculum consists of purely free resources that I've compiled
from across the web and has no prerequisites.
You don't even have to have coded before.
I've designed it for anyone who wants to improve their skills and find paid work
asap,
either through a full time position or contract work.
You'll be learning a host of tools like sequel,
python,
Hadoop,
and even data storytelling,
all of which make up the complete data science pipeline.
Data Science is the area of study involving extracting insights from data and a
data scientist sits at the intersection of math,
software engineering and data communication or the ability to communicate
insights from data.
There are a lot of related positions in the field ranging from machine learning
engineer to data analyst to business analytics specialist.
Usually a data scientist is expected to formulate the questions that will help a
business and then proceeds to solve them while a data analyst is given questions
by the business team and pursues a solution with that guidance.
On the other hand,
uh,
machine learning engineers goal is to build an optimized predictive models.
There's a lot of intersection between data science roles,
but the data scientist is usually the most senior role.
For example,
if we look at a data scientist job position hiring page at one of the big four
tech companies like Google or Facebook will see that they expect several years
of experience and a relevant undergraduate,
sometimes even graduate level degree.
That's because they can afford to do that.
Everyone wants to work there and they have more data than anyone else on the
planet,
so they set the bar very high,
but don't get discouraged by that.
If you're applying as a first time data scientist,
it's best to avoid applying there and instead of applying to a lesser demanding
role like a data analyst,
data science jobs at smaller companies are much more forgiving and you can make
up for both a lack of experience and any gaps in formal education by showcasing
the depth of your skills.
If you start your career there,
you can work your way up to one of the bigger companies or of course start your
own data science business.
I've divided curriculum up into three months.
The first month focuses on data analysis.
Month two is all about machine learning and the last month we'll have us learn
production grade tools like spark and Hadoop that data scientist use in the real
world.
Before I start describing the curriculum,
keep in mind that we are practicing accelerated learning.
Yes.
Each week of my curriculum consists of a full online course that's supposed to
take several weeks,
but we're concerned with efficiently downloading as much knowledge into our
brains as fast as possible.
To do this watch course videos at two x or three x speed using a browser
extension,
dedicate two or three hours every day to studying handwrite notes as you watch
for increased memory retention,
which has been proven and complete.
Just one of the projects of your choice from each course at the end of the week
to help synthesize the ideas you've learned.
Also while you're learning,
immerse yourself in the community by following this great list of data
scientists.
For the first week,
we'll want to learn python,
perhaps the most important tool in the data science pipeline.
It's a highly versatile programming language that's used across many different
industries at x has developed a great course made for absolute beginners to
learn python specifically for data science.
It takes us from Python language fundamentals up to creating plots using real
data.
Additionally,
I've developed a fun learn python for data science playlist,
so definitely check that out.
Once we have a basic grasp of python.
In the second week we'll want to take the statistics and probability course.
At Khan Academy.
It's actually really fun and Khan Academy's website has gotten better every
year.
The course has interactive content and they make it feel like you're playing a
game due to the mastery points system.
It covers topics like probability distributions,
random variables and hypothesis testing,
all of which are supreme,
really useful in the data science pipeline.
After we have a bit more of a mathematical foundation,
we can start learning how to perform all sorts of exploratory data analysis
techniques,
some of which use probability and statistics.
This is the process of summarizing the main characteristics of a dataset.
Georgia tech released a course called introduction to computing for data
analysis that demonstrates how to preprocessed analyze and visualize a dataset.
The important thing about this course is that most of the focus is on data
cleaning and in the real world,
data scientists will be quick to tell you that most of their time is spent
cleaning data.
Real world data is messy.
It's not like Kaggle where we get neatly packaged datasets.
It's unlabeled.
It's got missing values,
irrelevant features.
So learning how to carefully sculpt a Dataset so that it's ready for further
analysis is crucial.
Speaking of Kaggle,
the website has become a phenomenal resource for data science enthusiasts.
It's become not only a place for data scientists to compete for prize money,
by solving problems for companies,
but an incredible learning resource.
In fact,
Kaggle has a learn section that contains courses on a series of tools you'll
need to understand data science.
Each course is a series of well documented Kaggle kernels,
which are their version of Jupiter notebooks.
My only gripe is that there's no video content or assignments,
but an awesome resource.
Nonetheless,
definitely something to browse for week four,
spend the week solving a Kaggle competition that you personally find
interesting.
That's the best way to stay motivated.
Pick a completed competition and briefly view one of the colonels to get some
sense of what people have done before.
Then create your own repository and get to work.
Document the project very well on your get hub profile so that anyone who views
it can run the code if they follow your instructions,
including any future employers.
Remember,
get hub is the new resume.
Now that we know how to clean a Dataset and explore,
it's different features and relationships,
we can start diving into the art of machine learning.
Machine learning models help us derive insights from data sets,
correlations,
classifications,
clustering.
There's a lot of possibilities.
There are several mathematical disciplines that make up ml and I've got a cheat
sheet for each of them that list the most relevant parts you'll need to know in
the video description.
Columbia has an excellent course called machine learning for data science and
analytics on Ed ex.
It starts with concepts like search trees and linear programming applied to a
real world personal genomic Dataset to give us an algorithmic foundation.
Then it moves into popular machine learning techniques except for deep learning.
Deep learning is a subset of machine learning focus on just one type of model.
Neural networks,
the online deep learning books specifically parts one and two will get you up to
speed on deep learning very fast.
Suspend Week seven reading that.
Additionally,
I've got a deep learning playlists on youtube that's very extensive for week
eight.
It's time for Kaggle project number two.
This time with a focus on different ways of using either machine learning or
deep learning to solve a problem.
Our last month we'll focus on learning how the modern data science pipeline
works.
Data sets usually live in databases,
so learning how to work with databases is important.
You Udacity is intro to relational databases is a relatively short but detailed
introduction to the basics of structured query language or SQL and database
design as well as the Python Api for connecting python code to a database will
also fit in another short course into this week on the other type of database.
No sequel.
The intro to no sequel data solutions course by Microsoft on Fedex is perfect
for this.
It leads us through the three bs of no sequel variety,
volume and velocity.
By demonstrating popular examples like Mongo DB for we tend,
we'll move onto Hadoop and MapReduce.
As Google grew,
it had to index more and more data over a billion pages of content and in order
to cope they invented a new style of data processing known as MapReduce.
Hadoop was created to apply these concepts to an open source framework that
anyone could use.
Data scientists use MapReduce to process data frequently and the intro to Hadoop
and map by Cloudera course on your Udacity is the perfect way to get familiar
with these concepts.
There's also another framework called spark that is newer than Hadoop and is
getting a lot of attention because it's useful in different ways.
Think of it like an extension of Hadoop.
Stanford has a one day workshop on spark and we can use the associated slide
deck tutorial to learn more.
When you're working on a team as a data scientist,
often you're tasked with communicating your results to people in different
teams,
so important business decisions can be made.
Microsoft has a course on ed ex called analytics storytelling for impact.
That perfectly fits this use case.
And for the last week,
complete one more Kaggle project.
So you have three great demos to show the world.
Once you finish this course,
you can start applying for jobs,
doing contract work,
start your own data science consulting group,
or just keep on learning.
Remember to believe in your ability to learn.
You can learn data science,
you will learn data science,
and if you stick to it,
eventually you will master it.
Oh,
and find a study buddy to keep you motivated.
I've created a data science in three months channel in our slack group to help
you find one good luck wizard.
I'm rooting for you.
Please subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now I've got to clean my data.
So thanks for watching.